hey if you'd like to support the
production of more move university video
tutorials then please visit the support
move section on move university comm
thank you and enjoy so now that we've
got squalene stage 4 can happen which is
squalene siccolas ation so I've drawn
squalene here but it's kind of oriented
in a way that you can hopefully see how
we're gonna make the a B C and D rings
that make up the steroid nucleus start
with squalene here in the first step
we're going to do is we're going to have
molecular oxygen come in and come off as
water this water coming off there one of
those oxygens gets attached to here to
make this squalene Epoque side and this
step requires an NADPH talking reductive
biosynthesis here so this makes sense
and this is catalyzed by squalene mono
oxygenase to give us the squalene Epoque
side once we have this squalene Epoque
side here it's going to happen is that
we're basically gonna form these rings
where these pink dotted like this light
pink dotted lines are and the electrons
that are going to come from here so
let's actually do this in green so these
are like these electrons will come here
these electrons will go there these
electrons will go here and these
electrons will go there and these
electrons will come off to go onto this
oxygen and they're eventually going to
pick up a proton in the next step okay
they're going to pick up this proton
which will protonate the be minus charge
on the oxygen get the results here and
we're going to get this cation here this
pro sterile cation now it's put here in
brackets because this thing being a
cation is a short-lived intermediate
because of this positive charge here and
that positive charge there is because
once these electrons leave up top this
carbon here has that positive charge
that formal charge so this pro sterile
cation results and the the negative
charge
oxygen that resulted from this way Lina
Pok side breaking up here would get that
that age plus there that that protonates
that oxygen and then we have our four
rings we have our steroid nucleus in
this pro sterile cation ABC and D rings
so you can kind of see how cholesterol
might result from this now obviously it
doesn't look exactly like cholesterol
there's some methyl groups here and
there's this double bond doesn't need to
be here and there's it's not exactly
cholesterol quite yet but you can see
how how this would come about now this
intermediate form is in a two-step
process catalyzed by lanosterol synthase
so the second step here the cation is
converted to lanosterol which is shown
here and when l sterile is one of the
key precursors to cholesterol the end
product and you can see how how similar
this is to cholesterol but it has 30
carbons so we need to get rid of three
carbons that we do need to move some
things around here to get our final
product which is of course cholesterol
shown here right but there's a bunch of
steps in between these two in between
this line of sterile and between this
cholesterol in fact there are 19 steps
and the way we were going to actually
lose those 3 carbons one of them comes
off as a formic acid which looks like
this so that's one carbon there that's
just that one carbon right there that's
one carbon and there's also going to be
two carbon dioxides that come off so
that's two carbons there so those 3
carbons come off of Lanna sterile well
maybe not lettuce they're all exactly
but 3 3 of the carbons that are in that
molecule are going to leave to end up
giving us cholesterol which is our final
product
now these 19 steps I'm not exactly sure
the details most textbooks and really
sources of information that I found and
of just writing 19 steps that I
eventually give us cholesterol they
don't actually show exactly what's going
on there and I looked into a couple
publications and they also don't really
get into too many details they mentioned
some stuff but I was really entirely
certain about it so I apologize if you
actually need to know these 19 steps but
chances are if you're taking an
introductory course this should help
quite a bit and what I really do hope it
was helpful thank you for watching and
that's basically it to get a cholesterol
thanks for watching and be sure to LIKE
comment subscribe and share the video
with anyone you think might find it
helpful thanks happy studying